hundreds of German politicians have
fallen victim to a hack of their
personal information the stolen data
includes cell phone numbers and credit
card details which were posted to
Twitter Germany security agencies are
investigating who is responsible isn't
yet known and the government says the
hackers targeted lawmakers at all levels
even German Chancellor Angela Merkel has
been affected the leaked data includes a
fax number email address and several
letters purported to come out of her
office it's not clear if the leaked
documents authentic simply however even
if a large part of the data concerned
were authentic experience shows that in
such cases falsified data may also have
been mixed in hundreds of other German
politicians from every German political
party were targeted by the hackers they
then used Twitter to make public
personal data such as phone numbers
identification documents chats invoices
and even photos of their children
Germany's Justice Minister Katarina Bali
condemned the leaks as an attack on the
country's democracy the lefts faction
co-leader says he's deeply shocked it's
an attack on the social cohesion of our
country I've read and heard that many
artists journalists and politicians are
affected the aim is obviously to create
a climate of fear a climate of
insecurity in our country
the leak was first discovered Thursday
evening however it appears the first
document started appearing in December
with the Twitter account releasing
information daily in the style of an
event calendar none of the internal
documents that were released are
reported to be highly sensitive at the
moment there is no known suspect
normative ation it's not the first time
that German politicians have been hacked
russia was accused of a series of cyber
attacks that stole data from computers
in the german parliament in 2015 and
last year the German government's IT
network came under a fresh attack
Russian hackers were allegedly also to
play
our political correspondent maximilliana
Koscheck is following the latest updates
for us max personal data here as we've
heard has been leaked on cell phone
numbers credit card details the
government spokesman has said that no
highly sensitive data has been leaked Oh
what do they mean by that well there's
always different categories in which you
can consider data leaks or hack attacks
like the suspected one that we're
currently talking about the attack or
the leak that we're currently talking
about is one that contains a lot of like
a mass of data and in that is a mixture
of a lot of personal data but expert
have already confirmed that some of the
information has been publicly available
for example has been drawn from public
websites such as the German Parliament's
website some of the information that has
been supposedly leaked has come from all
the leaks for example from a 2012
Facebook hack attack where personal data
has already been leaked and some has
been falsified
so experts are currently looking into it
and it's important to note that the
original leak Twitter account has
already been shut down but of course
there's still circulation of the links
that have been distributed on the
Internet
max this is a serious breach we saw in
our report also the Chancellor being
affected what are authorities doing to
deal with this well currently we know
that the federal agency for information
security is meeting with intelligence
services the German government has also
been informed and they're now launching
an investigation we have it on good
authority that the American services are
helping on that and of course it's
important to note very crucial for
Internet users out there the links are
still circulating and it's advice that
you should not open them because even
though it's quite tempting there seems
to be information also on celebrities
German celebrities but also and
potentially well-known figures such as
German Chancellor Angela Merkel that you
do not open these links because they
could contain malicious software max
this is not the first hack on German
politicians on German government
networks in recent years a Russian group
was suspected behind the attacks is
there any indication
who was behind this data leak no there
isn't there has been a quick sort of
remarkable note that it was looking like
the far-right party AFD has not been
affected from the league but now
politicians of that party have come
forward and said that they have been
affected too however this what it seems
is like this is an attack or a leak that
is aimed to sort of look at like
psychological warfare so personal data
everybody can be affected even the most
powerful people in Germany and so what
is different to previous leaks is that
those were for example attacking
critical infrastructures public services
or the German parliamentary technical
infrastructure and those kind of attacks
the ones that have been happening
previously were always attacks that were
looking like for an espionage this one
seems to be more something that is like
aimed at showing how easily everybody
can be targeted and how everybody in
Germany and everywhere in the world
should be taking care of their personal
cybersecurity all right our political
correspondent Maximilian a Koscheck
covering the story for us thank you very
much